today on the matt welsh show yet another
police shooting sparks outrage and
protest this time a 13 year old boy is
killed as always everyone is blaming the
police but
i think we should move the conversation
from policing to parenting
that's the real source of the trouble
and the thing that nobody seems to want
to talk about also five headlines
including the democrats begin their push
for reparations while a bunch of white
celebrities come out in support of the
idea
and the media baselessly smears ron
desantis in the most vile way imaginable
finally in our daily cancellation we'll
discuss the scientists who've now begun
creating half
monkey half human hybrid embryos what
could possibly go wrong or better yet
what could possibly go right with a plan
like that all of that and more today on
the matt walsh show
so with riots already happening in
multiple cities and outrage still
exploding over the police killing of
dante wright and the country on edge
leading up to the verdict in the derek
chauvin trial chicago decided that now
this week of all times would be a good
time to release the body cam footage of
the officer-involved shooting of a
13-year-old suspect
you might also you might you might
almost begin to think that people in
positions of power
in this country want the riots in fact
if you're only beginning to think that
now then you're rather slow on the
uptake i would say
the incident happened on march 29th of
this year a little more than two weeks
ago
officers were called to the scene in
downtown chicago at 2 30 a.m
because someone or some group of people
were shooting guns in the middle of the
city
police sensors picked up nine shots then
9-1-1 calls started coming in
one caller reported six or seven shots
another also reported multiple shots
when officers arrived to the area they
immediately began chasing two suspects
the first a 21 year old man
named ruben roman they were able to
quickly catch and subdue
the second suspect was someone that we
now know as
13 year old adam toledo but of course
the police
didn't know who he was or his age all
they knew that was that people were
shooting guns and
now here's someone running away body cam
footage shows police chasing toledo down
an alley
where he stops turns
puts his hands up and is shot officers
render aid immediately but he dies at
the scene
this at least is the version of the
story that the media and the activists
want us to take to heart in fact cbs
released a cropped version of the
footage
so that this version is all you see
exactly as i just described it in truth
if you literally widen the frame
you discover that toledo was holding a
gun a gun that he
or the 21 year old suspect or both of
them uh were just moments earlier firing
at something or someone
toledo initially flees while holding the
gun
then as officers scream at him to stop
and put his hands up he halts
turns gun's still in his hand and subtly
tosses the gun behind a fence
with his right hand obscured by the time
the officer fires a single shot that
kills him toledo's hands
were empty but there was literally a
fraction of a second in between toledo
holding the gun
and the officer firing the shot from the
time that you first
see the gun on the body cam footage to
the point where the officer fires the
shot
eight tenths of a second elapse that's
it
toledo did try to surrender but it was
too late
and he purposefully ditched the gun in a
way so the cops wouldn't see him
ditching it
from the cops perspective this is a
suspect just involved in some kind of
shooting
holding a gun who is now turning and
raising his hands
now that officer has less than a second
less than a second
to make a decision is he raising his
hands
to put his hands up or is he raising his
hand because he's drawing up and he's
about to fire
if the officer guesses wrong he's dead
it is as high as the stakes can get and
he had eight
tenths of a second to decide which way
he would go
now i don't know about you i've never
confronted an armed person in a back
alley i've never had that experience
i've never confronted any armed person
at all especially not in the dark at 2
30 a.m
i've never had to make a life or death
decision in eight tenths of a second
now cops of course are trained for this
that's true but they're also human
they aren't superheroes this isn't a
movie they are tossed into
messy horrible real world situations
and they have to make the best judgment
call they can in the moment
that's why so often the more productive
question we could be asking is not
could the cops have handled the horrible
situation better but rather
why was the horrible situation happening
to begin with
what could have been done to avoid that
situation entirely
see to me that's the question in this
case rather than blaming the cop who had
eight
tenths of a second to decide whether he
wanted to ever see his family again
perhaps we should we should ask why a 13
year old boy was out on the street with
a loaded gun
at 2 30 am this child had clearly at
some point in the past
gone down a dark path a path
both metaphorically and literally a path
that has led many young boys and young
men like adam toledo to the morgue
eventually usually not at the hands of
the police but at the hands of other
boys and young men in the community most
of the time
we know that if that if adam toledo had
survived that encounter with the cops
and then been shot and killed a week
later by some local gang banger
um as as happens you know hundreds of
times a year across
the the country the media wouldn't be
reporting it
protesters wouldn't be taking to the
streets over it and its name would not
be known
you know the left only cares about the
atom toledos of the world
when they die by cop that's the only
time
if they die literally any other way any
other way
the people pretending to care about him
now would shrug their shoulders and
go about their day so the question again
is
it's it's not why did the cop make the
wrong decision in eight tenths of a
second while confronting an unknown perp
with a loaded gun and a dark alley in
the middle of the night
the question is why did this encounter
ever happen at all why was that
cop put in that position
elizabeth toledo adam's mother has
spoken out since the death
she says that that her child was a goofy
fun kid with a big imagination
he likes spongebob squarepants and taco
bell and candy
she says that he wanted to be a police
officer when he grows up
now that all might be true but we also
know according to reporting from
journalist andy know that adam was known
in gang circles as
little homicide and baby diablo
cbs reports that he went missing two
days before the shooting
disappeared out into the street
somewhere and his mother didn't report
it
he also had gone missing a few days
before that in that case it was reported
but then he returned and his mom never
told the police that he came home
then he left again and she never told
them that he was gone
perhaps not surprisingly so far we
haven't heard anything one way or
another about the boy's father or from
the boy's father as far as i know
now if you would look at the totality of
the circumstances here
and come away with the conclusion that
the police
are the problem then you're not a
serious person or an honest one you're a
fraud and a coward
you're afraid to deal with reality
afraid to tell the truth
you know though you will not say it out
loud that what caused adam toledo's
death was not bad policing
but catastrophically bad parenting
the tragedy that led to the final
tragedy was parental neglect
now as parents we can't exercise total
control over our kids
okay they'll make their own choices
sometimes they're gonna make bad ones
sometimes very bad ones
but if your boy is only 13. and already
he's running around the city at 2 30 a.m
with a loaded gun and his gang friends
one of whom is 21 years old and they all
call him lil
homicide something has gone very very
wrong
in your home our cities are full of boys
and young men whose home lives have gone
very very wrong they put it mildly seven
percent are live
seven seventy percent are living in
homes without fathers
and that's just the beginning of it many
of these kids are given
no moral formation no instruction no
guidance
they have no one setting an example for
them
no role models no one to look up to no
one to show them the way
nobody like millions of kids in this
situation
have nobody looking out for them
police are the cleanup crew called in to
deal with the mess
they're not the ones causing the mess
what's causing the mess is the collapse
and abandonment of the nuclear family
and that's happening
everywhere in society and it's bad
everywhere
and you see the fruits of that
everywhere but in the cities it has
reached apocalyptic levels
in in the cities the nuclear family
basically doesn't exist anymore
if you want to know what a post-nuclear
family world looks like
look at the inner cities that's what it
looks like
adam toledo's death that's what it looks
like
you know i look at my own son my oldest
he's almost eight
and i think to myself could he become a
gang banger running around the city with
a gun by 13
in just seven years could he go from
where he is right now
to that in seven years now the answer
for us is no
me and my wife would never allow that
but theoretically
would it be possible to turn my innocent
sweet little boy into a hardened
criminal by the time he reaches middle
school
theoretically sure i mean the first
thing i'd have to do it's very easy for
me actually all
that i would have to do is leave
um that might be all it takes if i
personally as his father
checked out of his life either
physically or mentally or both
that might be enough but if it isn't
then the next step is to deprive him of
all other forms of moral guidance
to ensure that all of his role models
especially his male role models are bad
influences
take me out of the picture and replace
me with the internet pop culture rappers
movies
next my wife would have to allow him to
get mixed in with a bad crowd spend all
day next thing you know all night with
these kinds of people
that's his new family that's where he
takes his social cues
that's how he learns to be a man let him
stew in that environment an environment
of confusion and abandonment and neglect
for a couple of years and uh just like
that my boy could be
the one in that body cam footage
anyone's boy could be
what does that mean it means that our
children can't raise themselves if the
lord of the flies has taught us anything
it's that
our children need us they need parents
adults to mold them boys especially need
men
fathers to guide them help them harness
their masculine energy in productive
and edifying ways you know boys are risk
takers
boys are aggressive that's natural
that's good it has to be harnessed
i can see that in my in my sons they
want to take risks
they want to be aggressive that's why
the father steps in and says okay you
want to take risks here are some
healthy controlled risks you can take
let's go climb a tree i'll be standing
right there
you know you you have a lot of
aggression let's let's wrestle around on
the floor
let's uh let's play football let's you
know let's go run around outside
that's what that's that's what boys need
fathers for
it would seem that adam toledo didn't
have that
and that's what signed his death warrant
the cop will live with the guilt but
he's not the one
okay he's not the one who put that boy
in that alley
with that gun now let's get to our five
headlines
[Music]
you know as conservatives we say we love
the constitution but
very few of us i think have actually
studied it and probably fewer stand
ready to defend it and that's where my
friends over at constitutioncoach.com
come in it's where they've got a lot of
great programs for equipping citizens to
defend liberty by studying and living
out the constitution
and that's why i was so grateful to go
and experience their constitutional
defense course
and it's why i encourage you to do the
same you get an amazing combination of
intellectual ammunition and live classes
with rick green america's constitution
coach
and you also get the physical training
at the premier firearms training
facility in the nation you get this all
in the same course
you get to join hundreds of others uh
other patriots from across the nation
for fellowship
training um and learning and it's a lot
of fun and
you come away with a very valuable skill
in fact whether you've shot guns your
whole life or you've uh or you've never
even touched one wherever you fall
in that spectrum i'm telling you these
people they took me to an entirely new
skill level they could do the same for
you
but you got to go to
constitutioncoach.com rick of the
constitution coach team
have another class on april 25th but
you're coming up on your last chance to
sign up
so sign up now go to
constitutioncoach.com again
constitutioncoach.com
uh you know one other note about this i
i i just saw
mom's demand action the uh gun control
nut cases they they tweeted
um about this case they said uh update
video released today shows that adam
toledo a 13 year old boy
a 13 year old latinx boy who was fatally
shot by police in little village
illinois on march 29th had his hands up
when he was shot and shows no indication
that toledo was holding a gun now that's
not true
the the as we just discussed as we just
discussed the body cam footage clearly
shows
that he did have a gun um and only eight
tenths of a second elapsed between when
he had the gun
and when the cop pulled the trigger but
i i
i'm really looking at le tanks boy like
are you are you really doing that at a
time like this
this boy has died can could we take a
break from that
can we take a break from that bs for a
day like can the lgbt agenda take the
day off
you folks have had you know you've been
pretty active take a day off
we don't need the latinx thing you don't
need to try to inject that
into this i
i it's incredibly disrespectful because
the latino community they don't use that
word latino people do not use that word
that is a white lgbt liberal word
that you are imposing on them and you're
doing it now um
you're using the opportunity of a boy's
death to do that
it doesn't even make sense because le
tinx is supposed to be
gender neutral you're talking about a
boy
a gender-neutral boy latinx boy
he's a boy latino they have there's a
word for that they have that word in
their community and
you should use the word out of respect
and also because it's a real word
it doesn't we don't need to change it
you know the irony is that so often
we hear this these claims of
appropriation we hear about
uh white white people colonizing foreign
cultures and
imposing their values and ideas on those
cultures
and nine times out of ten that those
claims end up being bogus
here's a real example of it here's an
actual real
example of white people white westerners
colonizing a foreign culture and
imposing their own values and ideas on
it
with this latinx thing except that the
colonizers in this case
and it turns out in most cases are um
left-wing liberals and so they get a
pass
all right number one this is from the la
times it says
a house committee late wednesday
advanced legislation first introduced in
1989 that would study the issue of
awarding reparations to this the
descendants of american slaves
um the house judiciary committee voted
along party lines to send a bill to the
house floor for the first time to create
a commission to study the legacy of
american slavery
of racist laws and how they affected
formerly enslaved people under
descendants the bill instructs the
13-person committee to
consider a national apology apology
and to recommend any appropriate
remedies to congress
um for slavery so this is a bill
this is a committee talking about a bill
to study
you know there are a lot of steps still
to go through
and um this goes back to 1989 so this
idea has been out there for a long time
up until a couple of years ago i would
have said uh this is political posturing
it's not
really going to happen but i think we're
at a point now where this will happen
i'll make that prediction right now i
think repara some kind of reparation
policy will be passed
uh it is with the the democrats
having total control of the government
right now
and white guilt being at its absolute
peak
um yeah i think it will happen
it's not going to be to the the to the
full extent
that left-wing activists hope for but
it'll be something
let's look at a few clips here of um
lawmakers debating this first here is
democrat hakeem
jeffries arguing for reparations let's
hear what his case is
i'm not going to move on because after
slavery jim crow
and the rise of the kkk and the lynching
epidemic
and plessy versus ferguson and black
wall street
in 1921 destroyed why because black
prosperity
was viewed as a threat to white
supremacy so no
we're not simply going to move on
and when the great depression struck
african americans were hit the hardest
and we received the least amount of
support
why because yes southern dixiecrats
insisted that in the new deal
african americans would be excluded
while other americans were helped
excluded from social security because
most of us were domestic workers
or many of us and agricultural workers
excluded from social security
excluded from unemployment insurance
and excluded from the federally
subsidized loans
and insured loans that were issued so
between 1934
and 1962 98
of the federally insured loans that were
issued by the federal government were
issued to white americans okay
rather than me responding to that uh i'd
rather hear from
representative burgess owens who uh
i i he you could find the clip online
it's like five minutes long of
everything he has to say about this idea
of reparations
well worth your time to listen to we
can't play the whole five minutes so
here's uh
here's a little bit of what burgess
owens had to say in response to this
idea
i'm looking forward to by the way
reparation when you take people's money
that they've earned is punishment it's
def
it's theft it's judgment
you're saying that because your skin
color you owe me
that is not the american way we're not
racist people
this american country is based on
meritocracy
and i tell you anybody who's been in
sports or or military you guys get it
at the end of the day it's the character
it's resolved it's a loyalty that makes
a difference
the color of skin has nothing to do with
how we choose those people that we want
to trust move forward with
yeah that's that kind of sums it up
that's what it is it is um
punishment vengeance
that's why i say what what what is
greasing the wheels here for this to
actually happen
is white guilt white guilt at an
all-time high
in this country especially on the left
but not just on the left this is
something that is being
drilled into kids heads from a very
young age
and it gets more and more intense as
they get older you get into a co
into college and it is full-on cult-like
brainwashing but the idea is if you're
if you're white you're guilty
of these sins from the past you're you
are
you have unique ancestral guilt
as i always say it's a very religious
kind of idea this is their religion
the idea of inherited guilt only in this
case it is it is
racially inherited guilt
like there's guilt that that flows in
the in the bloodline for white people
and this is an idea that many people
find very convincing and compelling
because it's been beaten to their heads
and that's why a lot of white people in
this country now would would submit to
this
having money taken out of their wallets
food taken out of their children's
mouths
to pay for a sin they didn't commit they
had nothing to do with
at all
now one thing that they that is rarely
clarified when we hear this idea of
reparations you heard when i was reading
from the la times article they talk
about
reparation for the descendants of of
african slaves
well even that is a horrible idea but is
that is that really all you're talking
about so
we're going to before we pay reparations
to a black american first we're going to
make sure they actually are a descendant
of an african slave is that is that what
we're talking about
because that's going to exclude many
millions of black americans who live
here now and are not descendants of
of african slaves because their family
came here
more recently than that but if we're
doing that
okay so if we're if we are um
if we're if we're gonna single out the
descendants of african slaves
then are we also going to single out the
descendants of
slave owners
what about the people who uh white
people who came whose families came here
well after slavery had already been
abolished
like me for example my family my family
wasn't here when that was happening
my family's largely irish which means
not only did they not own slaves but
when they came here they faced quite a
lot of discrimination
systemic discrimination as well
do i get some kind of reparation for
that
i mean you you could easily make the
case
that uh when my answer
my irish ancestors came here they faced
discrimination systemic discrimination
against irish people which was very
common back then
um and if in and you know that set them
on a certain
path and if it weren't for that i could
be in a totally different spot right now
i could be much richer much
much more well-off you know butterfly
effect and all that
you can make that case
but then if you're going to do that then
then you could really take anyone
and you could trace it back and you
could find the misfortune suffered by
their ancestors tragedies that befell
them
oppression they suffered
it would be very hard to find probably
anyone on earth
outside of like i don't know the royal
family
there are not very many people on earth
who um
do not have very real oppression
in their bloodline going back to their
ancestors
oppression persecution tragedy
suffering you know that that's common
for all people everywhere for all time
but
especially when you go back through
history
but as i said this all comes down to
white guilt and speaking of which
some celebrities including some white
celebrities have come out in favor of
reparations put together a psa
explaining why
we should all pay reparations and here's
that
lame argument against reparations
talking about slavery is keeping racism
alive or perpetuating the victim
mentality
no
if we were to stop talking about racism
tomorrow do you think that that would
stop
another unarmed black person from being
shot and killed
by the police do you
think not talking about racism would
change
the fact that black women are more
likely
to die during childbirth we're out of
excuses as a country
so please stop making them we built this
country on the backs
of black and brown people
and we still haven't really done
anything to say
very eloquent from chelsea handler as
always we haven't done anything to say
f well you're right i guess well i mean
she said she has done a lot to say that
she's
if if she has done nothing else in her
life she has certainly said that word
quite a bit
that will be that is that is the that
will be the
really the monument to hers at least she
that she used that word a lot
uh if look if you're a white well-off
celebrity
and you feel this guilt and you think
you need to pay reparations i've got an
idea
um pay reparations no one's stopping you
you can take your money give it to black
families
there are charities that you can donate
to there's all kinds of things you can
do
you could see them in that video sitting
in their comfortable homes
because what they're really saying is no
no it's not that i should have to pay
it's
all you people out there should have to
pay
i mean by by their logic they're the
most privileged so they should pay the
most
and and also who's the the first
celebrity we saw there the quote-unquote
celebrities that was alyssa milano
she said if we stop talking about racism
you think that's going to stop
black men from getting shot by the cops
well
in a way yeah i mean it may prevent some
of that
if we stop obsessing over race and race
related things
and if we stop telling people that cops
are um
homicidal racist lunatics prowling
through the streets looking for black
men to murder
if we stop saying that then yeah i think
we actually would cut down
on on the amount of of police involved
shootings
you know when you tell someone you take
a young black child and you and you give
that's the message that you send to them
from a young age
that the cops hate you they want to kill
you they want you dead
they're all they're all clan members and
racists and they're they're out there
hunting black men
and you tell a young black child that
yes you have greatly increased the
chance that
um he is going to have hostile
interactions with the police yes
all right one other clip i want to play
somewhat related patrice cullers is the
founder of
one of the co-founders of blm and
there's been controversy recently
because she
calls herself a trained marxist
and blm is a marxist organization
the founders of blm are very clear about
that it is a marxist organization
uh but even though she's a trade marxist
she has made a lot of money and then she
went out and bought four houses she's
investing in real estate
of course they're all in white
neighborhoods and there's been um
there's been blowback because of that on
both sides
left and right and here she is with mark
lamont hill trying to defend
her decision as a marxist to buy four
homes uh let's listen to that
there's also a critique though from the
left that would say
um if you are a trained marxist if we're
talking about a certain kind of radical
politic
that extravagant homes of any sort or
multiple
properties of any sort is itself
contradictory to the ideology that you
hold
so it's not about having money per se
but that it's about
uh or about property per se but it's
about there being a potential
contradiction between your express
politics and your lived practice
sure and i think that is a critique that
is
um wanting and i say that because
um the the the way that i live my life
is a direct support to black people
including my black family members
first and foremost and uh for so many
black folks who are able to invest
in themselves in their community they
choose to invest in their family and
that's what i've chosen to do
i have a child i have a brother that has
severe mental illness that i take care
of
um i support my mother um and i support
many other family members of mine and so
i see my money as not my own i see it as
my family's money as well right
yeah uh you know she was a marxist
translation i was a marxist until i had
money
that that's it it's it's really easy to
be a marxist
when you're broke you know
most of the the marxists you see on the
the internet advocating for marxism just
a bunch of broke
they're all broke a lot of them living
at home with their parents
really easy to do then once you have
money it's a whole different ball game
and the thing is what she said there
about hey you know i got my own family i
want to take care of my family
totally fine i i completely
sympathize with that i agree with it i
think your first responsibility is to
your family
it's nobody else's business you want to
buy four homes buy four buy 10 homes if
you want
totally no one else's business it could
be that you're being greedy and miserly
and everything else
even that is nobody else's business or
it could be that you're you're taking
care of people
you have a mother you're taking care of
you have a taking care of her brother
she claims
completely fine i get it yeah but but
see i'm i'm allowed to have that
position because i'm not a marxist but
you are
that is exactly the kind of argument and
logic that as a
as a marxist you have been arguing
against and shouting
down for years
is that that really is the whole
argument at least on the
on the at least the economic part of it
that that's the argument for financial
freedom economic freedom
i should be able to earn money and take
care of my own family my
my first responsibility as a man as a
human being is to my own family
and i should be able to take care of
them in the way
that that and to the extent that i want
i shouldn't have to explain that to
anybody i shouldn't have to justify it
and there shouldn't be anyone coming in
saying no you've taken care of your
family enough now you have to take care
of this family over here
now you have to take care of my family
yeah that's that's the argument that
we've been making but patrice
cullers um has not agreed with that
until now
and only for her
because i i guess that's that's the real
argument the real argument is
uh yeah but it's different for me she
should have just said that i think i'd
almost respect that if she said if that
was her whole answer
you know if marklemont hill had said oh
how do you justify this and if she only
said
you know it's different for me i would
say okay at least you're being honest
all right we got to play this you know
the left really really hates ron
desantis
um and when the left really really hates
you they will do
anything to destroy you anything so
here's joy reid on msnbc
along with her guest implicating
uh uh implicating ron desantis
in a sex trafficking scandal with no
evidence whatsoever
she's just tossing it out there let's
listen the question for gates because
obviously greenberg has to give somebody
bigger than him that would be gates
here is at least a per reporting the
people who were on that bahamas trip
notice if you see somebody's name
um that rings a couple of times you know
at least five women per politico you had
gates
um you had a guy named jason pirisolo
the hand surgeon and gop fundraiser
to ron desantis who apparently gates
wanted to turn into the attorney general
florida there's
halsey beshears a former state
legislator
and former appointed official in the
desantis administration
if you're ron desantis does this feel
like it's creeping closer to you because
these are your friends these are your
allies
yeah just as greenberg's lawyer said
about matt gates when he left the
courthouse the other day he said you
know what
if i were matt gates i don't think i'd
be all that comfortable right about now
you have to believe that desantis i mean
these are his boys these are his guys
right we've seen the pictures we've
heard the stories
you have to believe that ron desantis if
he has done anything
wrong feels like things are creeping
closer and closer to him
my god what what they sink lower and
lower by the day you keep thinking you
can't be surprised by but
what scumbags i i hope that ron de santa
sues them both into bankruptcy and
oblivion
i really hope i really hope that the
ron sanders sues them into bankruptcy
they lose their homes
then patrice cutlers could come in and
buy their homes out from underneath them
that's what i hope happens
my lord implicating him in sex
trafficking sex scandal
there is no evidence at all that ron
desantis has anything to do
with any of this oh but they're not
accusing him they're just
asking questions that's all
i mean just like i could ask the
question of the guy up there i don't
even know his name the guy
that we were just listening to i gotta
ask the question is he a pedophile
i'm not saying he is i'm asking a
question is he
he hasn't denied that he is
i mean you heard him speaking there did
he deny in that statement that he's a
pedophile
i don't know
um they really hate ron santos and
they're they're afraid of him
and that and that probably tells you
everything he needs to know about ron
desantis i think
tells you why he's probably he's
probably the guy he should be the guy
2024 they really don't want him
they really really don't want him to be
the guy they're not spending a lot of
time attacking trump anymore it's ron
desantis
trump is a different story and that's
quite startling in its own way because
you know they're not talking about trump
any at all anymore
trump has become and you know trump
fans out there are going to like me
saying this but trump has become a
cultural
non-factor like he he doesn't even
matter anymore
um he releases statements and that kind
of thing and makes no waves at all
the reason for that is that the big tech
has just wiped him out
big tech came in this is donald trump
okay
former president the most famous
and talked about guy and influential guy
in the world for the last like six years
big tech came in and said no you're done
we're done with you
you don't exist anymore and it worked
he's a non-factor
there might be something he can do about
that but um it's going to take a lot of
effort
you have to be very clever about it to
get around that
so far as it stands they have erased him
and now they're moving on to ron
desantis
and now the advantage also that ron
desantis has is uh he's not on twitter
i don't think um he's he doesn't really
rely on big tech
for for donald trump he
that was his game was to use big tech
like you know to use it to elevate
himself
and he rode that all the way to the
president's presidency which was quite
brilliant
but this double-edged sword then they
pulled the rug out
now he's gone um that's ron desantis is
doing it a very different way
so they're gonna have to do they're
gonna they're gonna find a different way
to get rid of him
all right um okay we gotta before we
move on to reading the comments like
we gotta do this article just because
it's really important this is from the
new york post
um and uh i'll just read this is the
news okay i'm just reading to you what
the news is
and it's important news it says they're
taking a shortcut
as the weather is turning warm men are
embracing extra short shorts
and twitter is loving it last week the
this is us
actor milo venti
made waves when he flashed his gams
while leaving the gym in teeny weeny
pants
his thunder thighs grabbed everyone's
attention and left fans wanting more i'm
reading the article okay
uh here's we have the picture up there
on the no oh my god
no that is not we cannot do this that is
not acceptable so what they're claiming
is that this is the fashion now
those are hot pants it looks like he's
not wearing pants at all in fact
is he wearing pants is he's even wearing
it looks like he's wearing a t-shirt and
there's no
he's not wearing anything underneath it
i don't know
what they're claiming is that this is
the fashion now um is men wearing shorts
like that
and i will say i'm not going to allow
that that cannot be the fashion
we're not doing this guys we are not
doing it
we're going back to cargo shorts there
was nothing wrong with cargo shorts
fashionable um quite handsome and
and practical as well and they cover
more of your pale gross legs
so the world doesn't have to look at
them
what the hell is happening with you know
jeans all so the fashion now is for
jeans we're going back to baggy
jinko style jeans while the shorts are
getting shorter
doesn't make any sense to me meanwhile
i'm over here wearing my polka dot shirt
everything is confused nothing makes any
sense okay let's move now to
reading the youtube comments this is
from
one user who says youtube now considers
you as offen
now considers you as offensive material
good stuff matt
fight the power yeah most of the
comments actually
i can't i can't do a full read in the
comments
segment today because almost all the
comments are about the fact that um
youtube censored our show yesterday
which they did
i don't know if they're maybe they're
doing it to this show too i don't know
but they censored the show yesterday so
that
they put a parental advisory on and you
had to sign
in in order to watch the show and then
you had to click through another
advisory warning of offensive content
and you also couldn't share they took
away the share function so you couldn't
share the show
what is their reason for doing it they
didn't give a reason
as far as i know um
what i will say is number one they
censored the show before it even
went on before it even went live they
had censored it already
we can only speculate and i will say
that the topic of the show yesterday
which if you missed because of all the
censorship and everything i would hope
that you go back and watch it after this
show
because it's an important topic we
talked about the ashley babbitt shooting
and the fact that we aren't being told
anything about the ashley babbitt
shooting and
she was killed by an unnamed federal
officer
in the capitol and we haven't been told
why we haven't been told who shot her
amber told his name or anything about
him that's what the
the title was about that's what the
opening monologue was about and um
youtube for whatever reason doesn't want
you to hear that
and yeah we did we we played the clip we
played the video of
ashley baby getting shot uh it's
upsetting it's not graphic you don't see
anything that's graphic but it's
upsetting maybe that's the excuse they
would give
is oh you know you played uh upsetting
violent content on the show
yeah well a few days before that we
played the the
video of dante wright getting shot and
they didn't censor that
um sophia says matt i saw someone riding
a skateboard on the main road
not even off to the side and wearing a
mask
i thought of you and wondered what you
would say about it well he's got his
priorities
straight you know saved safety first
he's skateboarding on the main road
where he could easily get hit by a car
but at least he's got the mask on
you know because when you're
skateboarding in the middle of the road
the number one thing that might kill you
is a virus so i wouldn't
yeah i would make fun of that at all
he's just he's got his priorities
straight
um finally sarah says hey matt it's
awesome you're so willing to redact any
false information you may accidentally
put out there i thought i'd let you know
that you slipped up again today the
earth actually is flat i'll let you
decide if you think i'm joking or not
cancel me if you must the thing is sarah
i think you're joking
but i can never be too sure these days i
have in the past
managed to upset the flat earth
community which is how i discovered that
there is
actually a flat earth community
and that's what i really that's when i
realized whatever little
it was at that moment that whatever
little faith and humanity i had left was
obliterated
and a full cynicism and pessism
pessimism from that day on
and i realized that no no idea is too
stupid for people these days
i hope you're joking but who knows you
know we have some really great mattress
sponsors on the show that i tell you
about and um and we all know that
the good mattresses are important
because you spend so much time in them
well if you're a parent you might not
spend a lot of time in them but you
still spend a good amount of time
in them and um and that's why you need
to make sure you're sleeping well well
you think about your mattress what about
the chair that you sit on you probably
sit on all day at work
that matters as well x chair um that's
what i'm sitting in right now extra has
you covered for all of your office chair
needs
the secret is not only their patented
dynamic variable lumbar support
which offers unbelievable lumbar support
to your lower back but now thanks to the
new
xhmt technology you can also get heat
and massage therapy
while you're sitting at your desk okay
you get all of that in one package
doesn't look like it's a massage it's
like a
regular office chair but um but it's got
all those
things in one package instead of your
old uncomfortable office chair now you
can look forward to spending hours
sitting in the ultimate therapeutic
massager
uh you just you can't go wrong but
you're gonna have the best chair
in the office or the best chair in your
house you'll be the you'll be the envy
of everyone else
extras is on sale now for a hundred
dollars off so go to xchairwalsh.com now
that's the letter x
sharewalsh.com or call one eight four
four
four x chair xr is a 30 day guarantee of
complete comfort
and you can finance your purchase for as
little as 30 bucks a month so go to
xchairwalsh.com now it's called
use code x wheels for free x-wheel
bladecasters
xchairwalsh.com you know yesterday's
troubling events with twitter and
project veritas should concern
everyone how they got you know banished
from twitter basically for exposing cnn
it's become easier and easier for big
tech to silence people they view as
problematic and this problem is going to
get worse before it gets better a lot
worse this is one of the principal
reasons why the daily wire has become
has decided to embrace a
membership-based business model we can't
become reliant on big tech we've gotta
we've got to be doing our own thing
that's what this is all about each new
member who joins us makes us a little
bit less dependent on big tech
uh building up our membership base is
the only way to ensure that daily wire
can continue to grow and thrive into the
future
so if you're already a daily wire member
thank you we appreciate you
um and if you're not a daily wire member
i hope you'll join us today
you know in fact it's so vital that we
quickly build up our membership base
that we're offering 25
off new memberships when you use code
censorship on dailywire.com
subscribe so go now with a sense of
urgency
use code censorship and get 25 off
now let's get to our daily cancellation
today we're gonna cancel everybody
involved in this monstrosity uh literal
monstrosity npr has the story that says
for the first time scientists have
created embryos
that are a mix of human and monkey cells
the embryos described thursday in the
journal cell
were created in part to try to find new
ways to produce
organs for people who need transplants
according to the international team of
scientists who collaborated in the work
okay now you might feel concerned about
any scientific endeavor that was
borrowed from the screenplay for the
planet of the apes
but no worries scientists and
bioethicists say that it's all good
this is all above board it's quite
ethical the article continues quote the
scientists who conducted the research
and some other bioethicists defend the
experiment
quote this is one of the major problems
in medicine organ transplantation
that according to juan carlos is
belmonte a professor in the gene
expression laboratory of the salk
institute for biological sciences in la
jolla california
and a co-author of the cell study he
said the demand for that is much higher
than supply
another bioethicist inso yun says i
don't see this type of research being
ethically problematic
it's aimed at lofty humanitarian goals
thousands of people die every year in
the united states waiting for an organ
transplant young noted
so in recent years some researchers in
the u.s and beyond have have been
injecting human stem cells into sheep
and pig embryos to see if they might
eventually grow human organs
in such animals for transplantation but
so far the approach hasn't worked so
belmont teamed up with scientists in
china and elsewhere to try to try
something different the researchers
injected
25 cells known as induced pluripotent
stem cells from humans commonly called
ips cells into embryos
from monkeys which are much more closely
genetically related to humans than our
sheep and pigs
after one day the researchers reported
they were able to detect human cells
growing in 132 of the embryos
were able to study the embryos for up to
19 days
that enabled the scientists to learn
more about how human cells and human
cells communicate
uh how animal cells and human cells
communicate an important step towards
eventually helping researchers find new
ways
to grow organs for transplantation okay
i'll probably give you more of that
article than i need to the only good
news here is that
this must be the thing that will cause
the aliens to finally intervene by
vaporizing our planet
i mean this has got to be it but before
we're all rightly killed or enslaved for
our collective crimes
it's worth reflecting on this can it be
ethically justified to create
a half-monkey half-human frankenstein
monster
if the end goal or one of the end goals
is to harvest its
parts in order to extend our own lives
that's the question the answer to that
question
is no and also what the hell is wrong
with you
i wouldn't call this even an ethical
dilemma or an ethical controversy
there's no controversy because this
doesn't approach the realm
of morally permissible behavior it is a
clear-cut case of science going
way way way too far in the words
actually
of dr ian malcolm of jurassic park um
your scientists were so preoccupied with
whether or not they could
they didn't stop to think if they should
if they should and yes in this case they
shouldn't
the problem is that while i can say that
this is wrong
and perhaps you can say that it's wrong
our society in general
doesn't really have any ethical leg or
monkey's paw to stand on here what we're
dealing with here
is the is the commodification of human
life in its most extreme form
or the most extreme form we've seen so
far more yet to come i'm sure
scientists are literally creating life
in a petri dish
to use it as a product as a good as
something to be used it is life as
commodity but it's only the latest
innovation in that space
right we've been treating human life as
a commodity for a long time we live in a
country after all where
human embryos are created and stored
like leftover ground beef in a freezer
if they aren't wanted they're just
destroyed
even children conceived naturally in the
mother's womb
if they're not wanted are destroyed and
sometimes harvested for parts
as we discovered with planned parenthood
now
if that's how we view human life as
something lacking inherent value and
beauty
and which only has value if it's useful
to us then sure why not make the monkey
people and start
cutting off pieces of them i'll take a
spleen actually just as a backup in case
i don't you know in case i need one
see the precedence already been set and
that's the problem that's what concerns
me
one other thought here to share and this
is a cheerful thought for the day
a good note to end on i think something
i've said before but i think probably i
need to keep saying
and it is this um
you are doomed you will die
right now as we speak the cause of your
death
is probably out there lurking waiting
for you
it might be in you it might be in your
cells it might be in your heart
or your liver dormant the clock is
ticking
or it might be someone down the street
some guy sitting in his office right now
making plans for the future but in six
months he's gonna run through an
intersection and t-bone you
and you will die and so will he
could be the point is you're marked
your death warrant is signed you will
die and then everyone you know will die
and soon the world will be free of any
trace of you and you'll be forgotten
and everything you ever did or thought
or said or felt will be vapor and ash
at least in this physical world what's
my point
my point is happy friday but also there
have to be limits to the lengths we will
go to
extend our short finite fragile little
lives
it can't be that literally anything that
extends life is acceptable and good
the effort is so fundamentally futile in
any case that doesn't mean that we
should be suicidal or that we shouldn't
value life
quite the opposite we should value it
immensely as we have so little of it
and for such a short while but if we
throw ethics and dignity out the window
just to cling on to our mortal frames
for a few more moments
is that trade really worth it and if we
ironically
devalue human life in an effort to
extend human life
how can that trade be worth it we have
destroyed the worth of the very thing we
want to extend
for the sake of extending it doesn't
make sense
so live your life take reasonable
precautions
go to reasonable lengths to protect
yourself treat your maladies
extend your existence we can't throw the
baby out with the bathwater
we can't throw out our dignity and value
in an effort to abolish our mortality
because the latter we cannot do
in the end we'll have given up what
makes life beautiful and good
and we'll still die anyway just without
the comfort of knowing that we had lived
with dignity
so look if you wanted to be cheered up
you came to the wrong place
if you wanted to be reminded that you
are canceled one way or another
eventually
then you came to the right place so
with that in mind i hope you have a
great um and uh
joyful weekend and we'll leave it there
have a good day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha thomachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way through the fall of the
republic with me
andrew clavin